Getting ready to have a shower
to go for my morning meeting
and I open the suitcase and I say,
"Holy shit, whose?"
And you see a clown suit.
And I see, I'm the idiot.
I always wondered who are the idiots
that take someone else's suitcase?
Then I would said, "Shit, it's me."
Aliza Peleg, thank you so much
for joining me on 20 Minute Leaders.
Good morning.
Hi, good morning.
Great to be with you.
It's fantastic to have you here.
First off, so we know each other
for many, many years.
We were recently reintroduced
through J-Ventures.
But the very first thing
that I saw about you is that
you are a board member of Asian Box,
which, like I mentioned to you,
is one of my favorite restaurants
of all time, based in California.
So, thank you for making it happen
and for allowing me
to have such a great meal.
Obviously, it's just one
of many, many things that you're doing.
I can't wait to talk about your career
and some of the insights
that you've gained.
Give me a second,
just give a brief introduction as to
some of the incredible things you've done
and then I'll let you take it from there.
But starting out
as a developer relations
for the Mac platform
all the way back in '91 with Apple,
to being a managing director at SAP,
to head of Global Planning
and Operations at Better Place,
one of the most revolutionary
and innovative companies
that spun out of Israel
with this great support of Shimon Peres.
Chief operating officer of PlanetSoho,
GM at NICE,
chief operating officer at Reali,
and now board members
of both Ayehu Software and Asian Box.
Aliza, incredible, incredible career.
But before we get into that,
you mentioned you have a fun story
to share with me.
Well, first of all,
thank you for that great introduction.
And it just shows you
how many years I go back.
And I have to thank you for being
a loyal customer of Asian Box.
It's been tough during the covid season
and trying to keep the service going
and feeding our amazing customers
with this very fresh and organic
and gluten free food
is indeed a challenge.
But we've been rewarded
by the phenomenal support
of our customers.
And keep it up and spread the word.
And we love your support.
So, thanks a million.
And that's really probably
the only thing that I've done
in my career,
which is not tech or software related.
So, it's an interesting,
it's a wonderful phenomena.
As for an interesting story,
I'm sure that there are tons.
The one that comes to my mind
is that I actually had
a breakfast meeting
with a CFO of a Fortune 500
with my pajamas.
How does that happen?
So, one of those 5am flights,
that means you leave your house
at 2:00 in the morning
and you pack a suitcase,
and I fly quite often,
so, I fly what I call in my pajamas.
Which is just the worst sweats,
the most comfortable T-shirt
and sneakers,
and just to be able
to sleep in the flight.
And this is pre business class
where they give you pajamas.
This is sitting in coach
with my own T-shirt and sweats.
And I fly for a meeting
in the morning with the CFO.
And I land at the airport,
and I didn't believe
this would ever happen to me,
I took someone else's suitcase.
Wow.
Which looks exactly like mine.
I travel an hour to the hotel
getting ready to have a shower,
to go for my morning meeting.
And I open the suitcase and I say,
"Holy shit, whose?"
And you see a clown suit.
And I see, I'm the idiot.
I always wondered who are the idiots
that take someone else's suitcase?
And I would said, "Shit, it's me."
And it was horrific.
Aliza, I always wonder
who is that person?
Who is the idiot that didn't check?
It was exactly the same color,
the exact same size.
The good news is,
it had a phone number.
I called the guy and I said,
"Joe, I have your stuff.
Don't freak out."
He obviously left my suitcase
at the airport.
I immediately called the cab.
It cost me one hundred euros
each direction to just to drop
the other suitcase
and come back with mine.
But there was no time
for the meeting.
And I just went in my pajamas,
with my sneakers,
with this crappy old T-shirt,
and I walked into this beautiful,
immaculate office.
The guy was wearing
a white starred shirt
with a beautifully tied tie.
And I said,
"I'm sorry. I'm in pajamas."
That's my story.
Wonderful. Wonderful.
And I amazingly we're into
the phenomenal career that you've had.
Most interestingly,
if I'm looking at this amazing list,
I'm seeing a lot of vision.
And we talked about this
very briefly before we started.
I'm seeing companies
that are really revolutionizing
whatever industry they're in.
And one of the things
that I'm learning to appreciate
both through Stanford and J-Ventures,
is that most companies,
especially in tech,
are not necessarily
visionary or revolutionary.
A lot of them are nice.
They're great.
They're building upon predecessors.
But here I'm seeing
a good cohort of companies
that are really trying to break the mold
and do something else.
Talk to me a little bit about
why you're attracted
to these visionary companies.
Yeah. That's great. It's true.
My career does span across
very small companies
and very big companies,
startups and innovative
and not so startup and innovators.
So, it's true that I have been around,
but I am really attracted
to the visionaries.
And I think what led me to it
was sort of one thing to the other.
I'm not a visionary as myself.
I think that my strengths
have always been around execution
and operation and progress
and sort of connecting the organization
and grounding the organization
to the founders vision.
So, I think I found myself
teaming up with entrepreneurs
that have a phenomenal vision,
but don't necessarily know
how to connect that vision
into day to day execution
by a team that's focused,
that's functioning,
and that allows them to really
and truly realize their vision.
And I think being in that environment
of entrepreneurship
and when we really, really
fighting for existence on a daily basis,
yet we can't just stay in the clouds.
And vision without execution
is actually not going to be
a great way to succeed.
It takes a lot of honesty and courage
and maturity to come and say,
I don't see myself
as somebody that's visionary,
but I know that my strengths
are connecting the dots
when you take somebody with a vision
and what needs to happen
in order to get to that vision.
And I really, it inspires me
because I think that,
especially growing around the community
that mean that you sort of expect
every young entrepreneur to be visionary
and all do it yourself
and you can do everything.
And having that honesty
and the courage to say
these are things that I'm good at,
these are things that I'm not good at
and I want to capitalize
on what I'm really good at.
And for you, that's the role
of the chief operating officer.
I haven't had the pleasure
of having too many COOs
on the show, not nearly,
especially with the background
that you have here.
What is the role of the operating officer
within both a small startup
and the larger organization?
That's great.
And I also want to,
before I go into the details,
I'll also explain
and maybe that's a fun fact, too,
it wasn't only that I
necessarily chose that
or understood that quickly early on,
I think I might have
demonstrated early on
and entrepreneurs
discovered that in me
and pulled me into it more than I said,
"This is what I do well."
I did work with an entrepreneur
without mentioning names
who started the second company
and wanted me to join and I said,
"You know what?
I need a little bit of time off between,
I'll wait a while
and I'll join you later."
And his answer to me,
"No worries. I'm going to start now.
You can join whenever you want.
I just want to make sure
that the later you start,
the more you'll have to clean up."
And then I said,
"Okay. I'll see you Monday morning."
And that was the end of my time off.
Because I think he coined it
better than I.
That's beautiful.
So, not so nice way to describe it,
is to clean up the founders
or the entrepreneurs
or the visionaries shit.
That's one part of the job.
One way of describing it.
A nice way of describing it
is really to try
and get the machinery going,
really to try and get a rhythm, right?
That there's a rhythm of planning
and executing and measuring,
learning from it, moving on,
planning again, executing,
measuring and learning.
So, it's something to keep
the organization accountable
to we know what we're doing,
we're doing it.
And we said we would do it,
And we said we did it.
And then we move on.
And have the ability to sort of
get that into some kind of a spirit
without being too bureaucratic,
without being too slow.
But if you don't measure
and if you don't really understand
and if you don't learn,
you can get off track
really, really quickly
and sort of forget where you started.
And sometimes the vision is so far out.
And this vector, you have to sort of be
quite sure on the vector
and now, it's okay to pivot,
it's okay to change,
it's okay to go in a zigzag.
But I believe in conscious zigzag.
And in understanding
and proactive zigzag versus reactive.
I love that.
So, do you see
a very big difference between
the chief operating officer of a startup
and that of a large company?
Because I'm sure
it's two different worlds, right?
On one hand,
you're talking about potentially cleaning
after that visionary's mess.
And obviously,
it's not because they're messy,
but it's because part of the role
requires that they do run quickly
and they try different things,
they break things.
And you need to have that figure
that comes and says,
okay, let's put some order here
and make sure that we're aligning
to our vision.
So, what are the sort
of the distinctions between the two?
Well, first there are distinctions.
And I just hope, for the sake of clarity,
I wasn't the COO in large companies,
in larger companies, I was more a GM
or a managing director of a big unit.
So, that was more
of an overall business leadership role,
either a line of business.
You know, NICE, I managed
the 200 million dollar line of business.
Or let's say, I was the head of,
I was the managing director
of SAP Labs in the US,
which was the largest lab
outside of Germany.
And I also led the lab network,
which was seven labs
outside of Germany.
So, that was a different kind
of an operating.
So, that's an operating role.
But it's not the COO.
In the startup world,
I think it really depends.
It's not appropriate for a startup
with seven people in the garage.
Right?
And you're just figuring out your product
and you don't really have
product market fit,
and you're still breaking things,
that's not really when you have a COO.
But when you've developed a product,
and we'll talk about
Better Place separately.
Because that was really from day one,
we were three people in the company.
Really?
It started in my living room.
We ran the company
for six months out of my house.
That's a different.
We'll talk about that.
But if we talk about
the general level of
startups, you know,
if you have been mainly
in the software world,
so, if you're six, five or six people
developing a small or a huge product,
but it's just the beginning
and you're breaking and you're not sure.
But once you start,
and when you say the word scaling,
it's scary because you can scale it
hundreds of millions.
You can also scale
from five people to 15 people.
But if you understand that
you're lacking some huge capabilities
around people management,
process management,
go to market management.
So, this is becoming
a little bit more functions
that are beyond the development,
the COO is not the only guy
who's doing the sales.
Right.
And either the CEO or the founding team,
take this upon themselves.
They really understand.
We need to start thinking about
our go-to-market.
We need to think about hiring.
We need to think about culture.
We need to think about processes.
If they have that kind of talent,
then there's no need for a COO
at early stages.
But when you need
when you feel, you know,
one guy is really the architect
and the other guy
is the head of the development,
then one guy can sort of
talk to investors and everything else
is falling apart in the process,
in the machinery, in the hiring,
in the HR, in finance,
then you start thinking about,
is there a person who can aggregate
all the sort of stuff
together and run it.
And then if you start going
to customer success
and you have support,
then you have got to,
so, the more functions you go,
depends very much on the composition
and the talent of the founders.
That's fascinating.
Aliza, I have to hear
the founding of Better Help
out of your living room.
I can't imagine anybody listening to this
who doesn't know what Better Help is.
Better Place, sorry.
Better Place.
Alon Matas from Palo Alto
is a great friend
and I've been talking to him a lot.
And Better Help is also
a fantastic company,
also a phenomenal company.
But better place is remarkable
because it really is innovation
through necessity.
A revolutionary story within Israel,
of course, with the late Shimon Peres
as a huge supporter.
And I remember growing up,
I think I was maybe 13, 14 when it was,
when I started seeing it roll out
in the big headlines.
And really what people
were excited about was
how revolutionary it was.
And here you have some
really courageous people
with a very courageous leader
in the government
that are running together
to really change the way
we think about consuming fuel
and how cars run on the road
and moving to a green planet.
Talk to me a little bit
about Better Place.
First of all, it's amazing
that you know so much about it.
And you were a young boy and it's great
that you spoke so beautifully
about the company.
You should have been part of our team,
probably even when you were
12 or 13 years old.
So, that's great.
It was absolutely
a phenomenal experience.
Unfortunately, it crashed badly.
And there's a whole session.
And I actually ran a small case study
at Stanford for 5 years.
Yes.
I run an annual case about
the rise and fall of Better Place.
Wow.
But an incredible, incredible leader
and a phenomenal visionary.
And we can all talk about
the billion dollar crash.
I wanted for a second,
put a plug in there.
I think that Shai Agassi, the founder,
the visionary and the leader,
I would say, probably, single handedly,
pushed the industry
to a point that that's why we see
so many EVs around the world.
The system didn't work.
The change didn't work,
we made a lot of mistakes
or the vision wasn't 100% right.
But if I can give credit to him,
the single largest credit
that I can give him is that
I think that he single handedly
pushed the industry
in his confidence, in his arrogance
in his lack of humility,
he walked into the heads
of all the auto makers and said,
"If you don't do EVs,
you're going to die."
In 2007,
we went to the Frankfurt Auto Show
and there wasn't one EV on the floor
or even a prototype
or even a demo car or nothing.
By 2010 or 11,
there wasn't a manufacturer
in the entire world
that didn't have an EV story
or an EV platform
or an EV strategy or something.
And then I think, Shai himself
and Better Place as his wing,
I think really, really moved that.
Even Elon Musk at that time,
who was already close
to delivering the Roadster
and delivered the Roadster,
even at that time, didn't publicly say,
I don't want to take away
from his vision at all,
that entire world should move to EV.
He was demonstrating
that if you were a Porche lover,
you can do that with an EV.
And EV is not a golf cart.
And you can have the best and fastest
and greatest car.
But mass consumption,
mass scale, no one spoke about.
And Shai really believe that
that could happen.
The reason in Better Place,
there was a head of operations
from day one because
that was a huge undertaking.
It was obvious
that Shai would be outbound.
Government's, financing
regulations, big outbound activities,
would have zero attention
and also less capability,
but mainly zero attention
into the company.
So, the entire processes
of starting to build the team
from scratch.
And wasn't [--]
so many dimensions.
Because not only
the product was complicated
from software and hardware
and batteries and all the physics
and all the capabilities of hardware,
go-to-market, the global expansion,
the regulations, managing the finance,
managing the people,
making the legalities right that we knew
would be incredibly difficult
from day one.
So, we started with that structure
that we would move forward with.
I think that's remarkable.
And I think sometimes we tend to forget
that everybody has 24 hours in a day.
I remember that a few months ago,
somebody mentioned to me,
we were talking about
the presidency of the United States
and we're talking about
how busy they must be
and the different things they get done.
And then he said,
"You know, the president also
has 24 hours in the day.
They also need to sleep
for at least five or six of them.
And so we're not very different."
I think it's sometimes,
it's easy to forget that
you can't have one person
who just does it all
who is both a visionary,
outbound, inbound.
And you need to have
those different processes in place
and be very honest about them.
Be very intentional about them.
You used the word intentionality
and the zigzagging in the operations
in the beginning of this discussion.
And I love that word.
And I take it to heart
and I'm very excited as I go
on my entrepreneurial journey
to remind myself
to continuously be intentional
about what I'm doing,
who I'm doing it with
and why I'm doing it.
But Aliza, tell me a little bit
about being a part of this team
that is really educating the market,
educating governments
and really going against
the grain at a time where no other
manufacturing company in Frankfurt
is showing any interest in it.
What is that like?
Well, it was great, it was tough,
it was excruciating, difficult,
but and it was also rewarding.
But it also had its challenges,
which eventually led to,
I believe, our demise.
Because when the gap between
your vision and execution
is widening instead of closing,
and also between
the story that you tell others
and the story that you tell yourself.
So, at some point,
I will get to it a little bit later, but,
it was huge.
Because we raised a lot of money
and because they were true
phenomenal believers behind it,
we could tell a real great story.
And you need a story
in order to drag people,
governments, countries.
So, you need a phenomenal story.
And we had that.
We had the money
and we had good storytellers.
And I think that creates
a very positive momentum.
And sometimes it's really hard
when I think of small startups
who have a great story
and they don't have the money
or the bandwidth or the capability
to actually tell it.
We sort of had,
we had the privilege to tell a huge story
and the means to tell it loudly,
loudly and beautifully.
So, at the beginning, you actually,
the momentum and the motivation
just coming from the
success of the stories
that there's so many people listening
and so many people buying into it.
So, it's misleading sometimes.
You get carried away.
You drink your own Kool-Aid,
which is a problem in of itself.
But that's how you get going.
You sort of really have to create
this positive cycle
of you tell the story,
people buy the story.
Then you tell people
that you told the story.
And we also hired phenomenal people.
And our team in Israel,
which was led by Kaplinsky,
they was amazing.
And their execution capability,
both in the operation,
building out the stations,
building out the prototypes,
getting the call to work in R&D,
an R&D team that I think
work more than 24 hours a day,
I have to admit.
So, I think there was a lot
of small successes and progress.
I wouldn't call it small,
that's not fair.
I think they were huge progresses
in certain domains
that helped us believe
that we're making great progress.
But actually,
with such a company,
all the chain is huge.
There are many links in the chain
and you're only as strong
as your weakest link.
And the fact that some links
were missing doesn't help the story.
That takes time to figure out.
And unfortunately, at some point,
I did feel
that I can't contribute anymore.
I can't really fulfill my role
as I should.
And I decided to leave.
Very courageous.
I can't believe that
it's spun out of your living room.
And one of the first three people.
I remember actually,
I was very, I still am
a very, very good friends
with one of the Shai children, Jonathan.
And we spent many,
many, many weekends at their house.
Shai is also a fantastic poker player.
And he taught us a lot about his skills.
And we were very passionate about
the behavioral economics behind it.
And during the games,
he would tell us a lot of stories
and a lot of inspiration.
And when I'm thinking back to,
why I'm so excited about technology
and why I was so excited
as a kid following this journey,
I think that was a huge part of it.
Seeing also from the background,
It's real.
It's not just in the headlines,
in the papers.
And the challenges are really tangible.
And at the end,
everybody's just a human being.
And we try to move the needle.
And I'm sure
that you have such incredible
fulfillment from knowing
that you really did move the needle.
And it's one of Israel's most courageous
innovative stories
ever since its founding.
I think it's just remarkable.
Aliza, I want to thank you
for being so generous with your time.
20 minutes go by very, very quickly.
But unfortunately,
the show is called 20 Minute Leaders.
I should have called it
an hour minute leaders.
But before we leave,
I have to ask you
the most difficult question,
which is three words that you would use
to describe yourself
and feel free to answer however you feel.
Well, maybe I can be
a little bit generous
with the definition of three.
Like a good Israeli
and negotiate with you.
There you go.
Yeah, I think.
Wow, that's hard.
I'll take a stab and I'm sure
it's not the real or the only,
I'm sure.
But it's the ones that come to mind,
I think that,
not necessarily in order of priority,
I think is,
in a not self-proclaiming way
But I think it's something about,
integrity and authenticity
would be my first in terms of
I really do speak my mind.
Sometimes people don't even like it.
But I really, really speak my mind
and I walk my talk.
I try very hard to walk my talk.
So, I think the second one
which might be related
is courage.
And the courage is,
it's not the same courage
as the visionary.
It's not the courage of thinking
how I'm going to change the world.
It's not that kind of courage.
But it's definitely the courage
of being with people like that,
not knowing necessarily a way
payroll will come tomorrow.
So, dealing with the fears
and uncertainties of a startup,
that's an easier courage.
The courage that I
think that I present is
I see [--] ramifications of me
doing the right thing.
My beliefs about doing the right thing,
whatever ramifications will bring,
I think that's courage.
And I wouldn't have known that
but I've heard people tell me that.
So, I think, that's a kind of courage,
you know, knowing that
if this will get you into trouble,
you may lose your job,
you may fall out of favor with someone.
But I think there's something.
It was wonderful until now.
Aliza, the walking the talk,
it's I think, not enough people do it.
And I think it's that courage
of actually executing on your intentions.
And we talked about
being intentional a lot.
And I loved when you brought up
the walk the talk with that first word
with integrity,
because its own world in itself.
And I think that,
knowing somebody that you can trust,
that you can trust that person,
and that you can really believe
that they'll do
whatever they say they'll do,
not necessarily that they'll do it right
or 100%, but that they'll actually be
intentional in doing it, to me,
that's what trust is about.
That's what partnership is about.
So, if it's okay with you,
I'll take that as the third word.
Oh, great.
I actually wanted to add a different one,
but I'm happy to.
It's a derivative, but that's perfect.
That's perfect.
I love it.
Aliza, thank you very, very much.
This was inspiring and thoughtful
and a lot more.
So, thank you for giving me the time.
And I look forward to keeping in touch.
Thank you.
Thank you for the opportunity.
It's been a lot of fun.
And now you owe me a cup of coffee.